[Musica]
sono nato il primo settembre del 1971
qui la faccio vedere per sfruttare a
scatenare un po di invidia ecco non è un
caso che io sia nato lì perché io
appartengo una famiglia che ha fatto del
viaggiare il proprio marchio di fabbrica
mio nonno dal 37 al 47 re in africa
orientale
nello stesso momento suo fratello
gemello stava in argentina
mio padre andò dopo la guerra in
argentina dove conobbi mia madre che era
nata vicino a qui ho 45 anni sono molto
curioso conosco un sacco di cose per
averle sentite ascoltate lette ma una
cosa la so da me viaggiare fuori ti
cambia dentro il mio primo volo l'ho
fatto che a nove mesi di vita
non ho nessun ricordo di quel volo però
qualcosa deve essere successo se poi in
seguito avrei fatto 250 voli di cui
almeno 34 intercontinentali i primi
dodici anni della mia vita io passati
tra i due continenti tra l'america e
l'europa tra italia e l'argentina ogni
quattro anni mediamente cambiavamo paese
e continente
in tutto questo viaggiare in questo
peregrinare la mia compagna di viaggio e
la mia sorella gemella con la quale ho
condiviso la scuola il tempo libero
quando io volevo che gli altri non mi
sentissero non capissero cosa volevo
dire le parlavo nel nostro codice
segreto che era l'italiano quando
eravamo in argentina lo spagnolo e
quando eravamo in italia ecco questa è
una cosa che io ho sono bilingue lo sono
a livello di poter sostenere una
conversazione con mio figlio parlando in
spagnolo e lei ris e lui risponde in do
min italiano di voi parla lingue
straniere sa che questa cosa non è per
niente semplice
io l'ho scoperto con mia madre mia madre
è una delle lingua spagnola ha imparato
l'italiano
quando era già adulta e io le ho chiesto
chiaramente di parlare con i miei figli
spagnolo ma lì non ce la fa quando mio
figlio
le risponde in italiano lei attacca
parlare in italiano e potete immaginare
io mi sono innervosito più di una volta
su questa situazione e mi dice e che
faccio confusione bene è proprio la
confusione la questione vera è
importante
c'è una interessante ricerca della
anglia ruskin university dove hanno
fatto uno studio tra bambini bilingue e
bambini monolingue e hanno scoperto che
i bambini bilingue sono molto più capaci
dei monolingue di mantenere focalizzata
l'attenzione e si sono chiesti come mai
è la risposta è questa di fatto ogni
volta che un bambino bilingue deve
affrontare la realtà almeno sempre due
etichette due parole che possono essere
utilizzate
e ogni volta deve tenerne una e
sopprimere un'altra tenere una e
sopprimere un'altra questa operazione
allena a lungo andare la capacità di
rimanere focalizzato rispetto a quello
che il lavoro che si deve fare è solo
questo il vantaggio non ce ne sono anche
altri per esempio l'università diventa
scoperto che le persone bilingue nelle
persone di lingue compaiono i sintomi
dell'alzheimer cinque anni dopo in media
rispetto in monolingue e altri ricerche
dicono che i bilingue hanno una capacità
creativa maggiore dei monolingue questo
perché perché tendenzialmente le lingue
ci aiutano a descrivere la realtà e lo
fanno con sfumature che sono diverse
queste sfumature non coincidono mai
sono sfumature che ci permettono di
descrivere in altro modo
in realtà e allora quando io ne ho due è
queste sfumature creano una situazione
che mi obbliga ad avere una profondità
maggiore nella conoscenza della realtà è
un po come con la vista se io guardo con
un solo occhio un'immagine piatta
se invece guardo con tutti e due gli
occhi o la profondità questo perché
perché ho due immagini che non sono
uguali hanno delle sfasature ma il
nostro cervello poi li ricompone ci dà
la profondità con le culture succede la
stessa cosa succede che in qualche modo
il dover comporre regole e comportamenti
i modi di vita diversi ci obbliga ad
avere una profondità maggiore di
comprensione vi faccio un piccolo
esempio nel 1983 appena tornato
dall'argentina
io in argentina avevo comprato una tuta
in felpa era una tuta che mi piaceva
monterà le prime che giravano ne andavo
molto orgoglioso e ricordo di aver
deciso di andare a scuola vestito con
questa tuta sono andata a scuola sono
entrato mi sono seduto e matteo il mio
compagno mi guarda e mi dice belletti ma
che fai
oggi non c'è mica ginnastica allora vi
ho capito subito perche mi sono guardato
intorno visto che effettivamente ero
l'unico che aveva sulla tuta ho capito
che in italia ha l'abito fa il monaco e
che ci andrai scopo per qualsiasi cosa
che tutti conoscono ma non è scritto
mentre in argentina uno può andare
vestito così come vuole
allora io mi sono in quel momento dovuto
interrogare su che cosa stava succedendo
e nel trovare una risposta
ho acquisito una maggiore profondità di
conoscenza rispetto a per esempio come
ci si veste e come il vestire non sia
una cosa data per assodata ma dipenda
dalle culture c'è solo questo no ci sono
anche altre cose per esempio riguardo
economic forum ha stilato una classifica
diciamo delle 10 skills più importanti
per il 2003
almeno cinque di queste qua possono
essere tranquillamente allenate
sviluppate nel momento in cui io abito
in un paese diverso
il concentro solo sul primo il complex
po benz holding che è fondamentale la
capacità di risolvere problemi
situazioni complesse
immaginate che allenamento continuo e
quotidiano a una persona straniera che
si trova a dover capire se le cose che
sta facendo sono corrette oppure no per
la cultura nella quale si trova un
allenamento continuo dal momento in cui
mi alzo la mattina al momento in cui
vado a dormire
insomma quello che voglio dire è andata
ad abitare all'estero
viaggiate fatte questa esperienza tra
l'altro se avete meno di 29 anni e
qualcuno quale sarà sicuramente così
avete un'opportunità incredibile oggi ci
sono mille modi per poterlo fare a basso
costo
io vi do solo due parole poi andate a
cercarle erasmus plus il servizio
volontario europeo sono due splendide
opportunità per poter viaggiare abitare
in altri paesi e sviluppare tutte queste
competenze praticamente pagando nulla
se poi non volete andare da nessuna
parte perché è il suo male di te ciò al
mutuo tante cose non ce la posso fare
be nice questo non è un problema perché
abbiamo il mondo dietro casa in una
città come torino basta andare un po in
periferia che li troviamo il mondo
troviamo una marea di gente che si trova
nella condizione che ho descritto prima
io con la tuta che continuamente si fa
delle domande su come noi viviamo e
cerca delle risposte
se noi fossimo in grado di cogliere
quelle domande quegli interrogativi ci
permetterebbe di avere una comprensione
più profonda della nostra realtà e
magari cambiarla anche del resto
l'innovazione questa roba qui no
l'innovazione è la possibilità di
mettere insieme dei diversi ma ci vuole
una narrazione nuova una narrazione che
sia più favore
pensate quest'uomo carlos pellegrini
italo argentino diventa presidente della
repubblica argentina a fine ottocento
questo avviene a 20 anni esatti dalla
prima massiccia immigrazione italiana in
quel paese e come se oggi a vent'anni
dalla prima massiccia immigrazione
albanese in italia avessimo un
presidente del consiglio italo albanese
possibile grazie
[Applauso]